[Music]
many would argue that for at least a
century we have been moving away from
the old moral certainties of traditional
christianity
yet now new forms of moral certainty are
appearing
with much of our culture seemingly
gripped by strong standards of virtue
and a closely police sense of right and
wrong
should we welcome this return to virtue
and embrace our new moralism that will
purge society of its newly found sins
or are these new certainties merely new
forms of prejudice
intolerant assertions of tribal
attachments
is our culture morally bankrupt and in
need of greater virtue
or could we be in the early stages of a
salem witch trial
so i'd like to introduce our speakers
for today
first of all matthew taylor
so matthew is a former political
strategist and regular panelist on the
moral maze he is now chief executive for
the royal society of arts
rebecca roach is a philosopher who has
written on a wide range of ethical
issues including technology death and
drinking alone
she is well known for her work on the
cultural power of swear words hillary
lawson is a post-post-modern philosopher
and a renowned critic of philosophical
realism who is best known for his theory
of closure
now we will begin with pitches from each
of our speakers starting with you
matthew should we welcome a new moralism
to purge society of its sins
um so uh i i think i approached this
issue more as a sociologist
uh anthropologist um
rather than a philosopher
and so uh my answer to this question is
yes but in the sense that i think we
need to think of morality as a system or
a part of a system
so you have a social system and morality
is one of the things that throws through
that system and when society is work the
moral system
tends to work and when societies don't
work the moral system is collapsing in
various ways
and one way to think about this is that
the three great systems that run through
society are actually
in all of you they're your three core
motivations so you're motivated by
authority
you're motivated by kind of belonging
values this kind of stuff you think you
ought to do and you're motivated by some
idea of autonomy and individual
self-interest and those three things
authority values and belonging and your
own individual story
that's what drives you but also the
level of society as a whole whether or
not the systems of authority the systems
are belonging and the systems of
individual aspiration are aligned
will tell you an awful lot about whether
that society is successful
at the moment in our society they're
very badly aligned and that's why things
are quite grim
so
if we were to get a better aligned
society it would have a moral dimension
and so
firstly we need to think about the
authority the moral authority the
morality that comes from authority so
that's the morality of doing what you're
told basically and obviously that's
weaker than it used to be religion was a
major source of that you know you don't
question the ten commandments or the
quran you just do it
and also because state institutions have
also weakened so institutions are wholly
weakened so that element of morality
that kind of doing what we're told has
become weaker and i think that's a
problem i think we need to renew
authority renew the legitimacy authority
i think societies do need to have a
morality that is in some extent based on
doing what you're told on the basis of
what has been agreed particularly by
people who are democratically elected
secondly
the morality of belonging
and there's an awful lot of that around
so populist politics is all really
around the morality of tribe and
belonging
and in some ways that's quite vibrant
but the problem is it's very
antagonistic so the morality of tribe we
have now is the morality of my tribe
good your tribe bad and that's why you
see the levels of polarization in
america between democrats and
republicans so democrats and republicans
americans believe they have no moral
responsibility towards each other at all
they think the other side is morally
reprehensible and we feel the same way
about brexit so we need to think about
how we get morality in groups to work
and then finally individually we have to
change our individual as counter
morality we were seduced by the nonsense
of homo economics and neoliberalism
which was we could have whatever we want
it will be great for society as a whole
climate change hopefully is the shock to
our system uh that teaches us that we
have to think much more deeply about how
we align our individual morality with
what is good for society as a whole so
it's a systemic issue and we need to
balance different sources of morality to
make it work so we need more moral
reawakening but in that broader systemic
sense thank you
[Applause]
straight over to you rebecca
should we welcome a new moralism to
purge society of its sins thank you um
i'm not sure i agree that we have a new
moralism i mean that there's sort of two
at least two separate issues sort of
mentioned in this um the description of
this this debate one is uh the idea of a
return to virtue and another is moral
certainty um
i don't think the idea of virtue has
really gone away so virtue is uh the
ideas a virtue is a character trait it's
not a sort of right or wrong out there
in the world it's it's a character trait
if you have the right virtues then
you're going to be disposed to
behave morally i mean i think that there
have always been
uh ideas of what are sort of virtuous
and vicious character traits or vicious
being the opposite of virtues um we
might have rethought them in recent
years so you know sort of a few decades
ago it might be thought that chastity at
least for sort of women is um is a
virtue um i think sort of quite rightly
we are sort of questioning things like
that we have other ideas that sort of
what what uh what being virtuous
involved but i think the idea of sort of
virtue as a an important
concept in thinking about morality is
still with it we're still with us but
it's just maybe the sort of thing that
we kind of only notice when it changes
you know when we start to re-question
what makes for a good or a bad person
and there's perhaps people disagreeing
about that that bring us to light um the
idea of moral certainty i think this is
so this is an issue that is potentially
concerning um it's hard to work out
what we should be certain about morally
um and the fact that people disagree
um should just be i suppose just be a
check on us that you know we might not
be right um you know if we have if we
have a certain set of beliefs if we
believe that certain things are right
and other people disagree with us then
that itself is um just a perhaps a cue
to us to sort of question whether we're
right
um i think there's something that is
potentially concerning is that in recent
years um there has there's been a
willingness to question certain things
that
seem like they should be unquestioning
you know unquestionable so you know the
the the the idea that uh we are all
all people are equal in moral status you
know they're sort of um you see this in
the you know matthew mentioned that the
brexit debate i mean you see this in the
news with people sort of um sort of eu
citizens living in the uk
saying that they don't feel like they're
being treated as sort of um
as
humans of the same worth as uh as uk
citizens um
and and then there's this sort of uh you
sort of see it with people like uh the
the the chairman of nestle who a few
years ago well you know i don't think
water should be a human right or that
it's not necessarily a human right or at
least that was what he was reported to
say and that sort of thing you know we
sort of have a shock response to that
which is like wow are you really
questioning that um it seems like you
know there's certain things that we we
think we ought to be certain about
morally and it can be really unsettling
if
people start to question them um so i
think there's sort of two sides to this
that there are kind of um that the idea
of people being certain that they're
right about moral issues is it
self-concerning because you know the way
that we learn and progress in our moral
thinking is through discussion and
debate but then there are other sort of
things where we think well surely we
should agree we should all agree that
sort of people are all off equal work
that sort of thing um and then it can be
it can be really quite concerning when
we encounter a sort of widespread
willingness to question that
thank you and finally hillary uh should
we welcome a new moralism
so well
more than 100 years ago at the turn of
the 19th century a philosopher called g
moore
um became well known for arguing that
there were moral facts
which we could describe
or not
accurately
and that claim
seems to me to have become increasingly
implausible
uh shortly before uh moore argued this
just 10 years really before
fraser and the golden bow listed all of
the different
systems of thought that people had
around the world and listed them one
after the other
and there were of course as many
different moral codes and frameworks as
there were
categories of people that he listed
and of course it then seemed rather
implausible that any one of these groups
of people
uh would have somehow stumbled on the
truth about moral facts
and the history it seems to me or the
intellectual history of the 20th century
has just embedded that awareness of the
particular perspectival character of our
beliefs so we now recognize we are
culturally historically
uh
dependent as it were and that even on
our language as a species we see the
world in a particular sort of way all of
these things mean the
the way that we hold the world is uh an
accident of our particular circumstance
and therefore the idea
that we might somehow have stumbled on
the true morality we found the good
when there are countless other frames
which have different goods and different
circumstances seems to me utterly
implausible
now
i think it's not just implausible
it's dangerous
so
if you look at people who think they're
good they're often capable of engaging
in the worst and most heinous acts
we don't have to look back to
the christian uh legacy of the crusades
and the inquisition where people who
believe they were acting in the good
tortured people who had slightly
different views from them
in contemporary life
the people who blew up the twin towers
and beheaded people in syria believed
they were doing good
so we should be very careful of people
who think they're doing good
and it's not just that morality is also
a vehicle of power
all of the parents in the audience will
know when your child has for the
umpteenth time demanded to do something
and you are fed up of trying to explain
why it is that you want something to
happen there is a great temptation to
say you shouldn't do that it's wrong
or you should do it because it's right
and you're just trying to bring the
conversation to an end you're just
trying to be the one in control
and that's what morality is about it's
trying to ensure that your view is the
one that
persists
and therefore again i think we need to
be very skeptical of people who wrap
themselves in morality as a means of
trying to get what they think to happen
but i'd just like to say one further
thing which is i think there is a sort
of transcendental esoteric sense to
morality which i would be in support of
which is that i think that at some level
we do
aspire to the idea of acting outside of
human limitation and try to act in a way
which is not dependent on a particular
circumstances in some general way to be
other than where we are now and that i
think is laudable
but we can't turn it into a specific
belief as soon as we turn it into a
specific belief then uh it risks all of
the things that i've said so
yes i think we should be skeptical of
conventional morality and we should be
just as skeptical of any return to
morality if we think that is taking
place thank you
[Applause]
okay so this brings us on to our first
theme where we're interrogating the
roots of morality
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai dot tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas